là où ça bouge nous sommes heureux
qu'apple hier à caen pour un
anniversaire les 30 ans de l'atelier
contes arts place au dessin ce soir
quand on est jeune on apprend le décès
un petit peu à l'école sauf qu'à
abandonner ce s'arrête vous prenez le
relais de l'éducation nationale alors
oui en quelque sorte je retrouve ici des
enfants à partir de 8 ans et des
adolescents qui viennent préparer un
métier avec moi
préparez des entrées au concours aux
écoles notamment olivier de serres boule
du père et estienne etc qu'est ce qu'il
ya de spécial c'est atelier est bien
celle de son maître
non il a à m exceptionnel c'est vrai je
pense qui sait s'adapter au style de
chacun qui n'impose pas sa conception de
la peinture et qui sait pousser chacun
dans ses retranchements travailler seule
ride
ici bon on va voir l'état des travaux
des autres on se confronte au travail
des autres voilà et la présence du
maître nous motive nous galvanise
pourquoi ça dure depuis 30 ans d'écouter
une ambiance une osmose une émulation de
entre artistes je pense que c'est
important de travailler en collectif
comme ça ouais c'est très agréable
et puis on fait une petite autocritique
chacune de notre travail ce qui est
toujours très sympa d'avoir le regard de
l'autre sur sa peinture 34 artistes
viendront donc exposée à l'atelier le
premier vernissage a eu lieu vendredi
dernier avec 300 personnes 150 le
week-end samedi et dimanche alors je
tenais à préciser aussi que
les personnes peuvent installer sur le
site de l'atelier contes à illizi
verront la fiche avec les travaux des
exposants les dates les vernissages tous
des vernissages sont ouverts au public
parce qu'en général c'est plutôt assez
privé avec les copains les amis et la
famille là les portes sont grandes
ouvertes
l'endomètre voilà on va souhaiter bon
anniversaire à l'atelier conte a donc
qui fête ses 30 ans de dessin est ce que
vous aimez le polar j'adore parce que
justement à fleury sur orne il ya bloody
fleury c'est le premier festival de
polar qui commence jeudi soir avec une
lecture en musique patrick mertz nous
dit tout on y va l'oignon dans un bol de
faïence je coupe la viande le temps que
lui soient plus chaudes
j'ai limpide à étouffer le grésillement
du beurre
et j'écoute le balbutiement vont être au
fond de la petite sauteuse
la viande est fine de grains souple de
pur
venu avec son duvet a rasé qui subsiste
de l'ancien fourrure ça fait un petit
moment qu'on travaille avec
françois-xavier en fait notamment sur du
répertoire jeune public avec le quintet
nous on a toujours essayé depuis multan
est de développer des projets avec des
gens à droite à gauche
aidons donc le répertoire jeune public
avec françois-xavier du coup voilà on
avait pensé à lui pour ce projet fort
sympathique mais là c'est pas du jeune
public
ah non c'est pas du jeune public les un
polar c'est du polar une lecture donc
avec l'ensemble pantagruel r un
quintette à vent ce sera jeudi prochain
en ouverture de brody fleury le festival
du polar à pluri sur orne
jeudi soir à 20h30 à la salle nicolas
aurait sme un fleury sur orne
qu'est ce qu'il faut savoir en premier
quand on achète un djembé pour commencer
à jouer mais il a droit sont là 300 il
faut commencer par sahin à prendre ces
trois sont là avant de commencer à jouer
donc ses 305 war vient de claquer un
tonique et la basse dont les claques et
il est légèrement les doigts et quartier
elle doit écarter légèrement qui donne
ce son et on fait travailler plus de
bout des doigts et tonique le doigts
légèrement fermer aussi première des
choses faut commencer par tony claqué
basse et apprête à l'accompagnement août
à l'aide trois phrases qui sont là
dessus c'est a dû le don pour commencer
l'accompagnement on peut faire et vous
lui rend un rythme en rythmique ça fait
et pour terminer une bonne nouvelle
jeudi soir sur france 2 à 23h55 une des
productions du théâtre de caen l'opéra
vénus et adonis